anyone else they're everywhere  and stay down  please welcome community manager for  Killer Instinct bukhari Austin thank you  I want to start by saying thank you to  the nearly seven million Killer Instinct  players out there your passion is what  has made ki the most played fighting  game on Xbox one it's because of you  that we brought ki to Windows 10 in  March and we're absolutely blown away to  say that since then two and a half  million matches have been played between  players on Xbox one and Windows 10 it's  also because of you that we brought in  incredible guest characters like rash  from Battletoads orbiter from Halo and  we're not quite done yet  so it's time for our next character to  emerge a special gift out there for all  those gears fans and we're excited to  bring him to the fight Xbox one and  Windows 10 exclusive  Xbox one and Windows 10 exclusive